الخروج من العاصمه السودانيه بين نيران
القصف والرصاص ليس كل الخطر وتخطي
المواجهات لا يعني انتهاء رحله النزوح
فويلات النزوح متعدده كما قال بعض الناجين
من الاقتتال وانا غير كده انا باخد
انسولين يعني انا ما اخذتهم ما في قروش
عشان انا اشتري منسولين انا خليت هناك
اموالي وحالتي كلها في الخرطوم وشغليه
الخرطوم فجيت مع الضربه اول ما حصل اشتباك
شديد انا خليت كل حاجه يعني وجيت معرفتها
ما امتلك اي حاجه هنا
مساجد ومدارس حلفا وحتى شوارعها باتت ماوى
للسودانيين الذين خرجوا تاركين خلفهم
ممتلكاتهم اخترنا المسجد عشان موحد واضحه
وقريبه من الخدمات ويعني متوفر اي حاجه
قريبه منها
الخيمه ده عمل لنا خيمه شمال اقعد في
الشمس والله ما شعوري شعوري يعني ما فكرت
انه نطلع من السودان من الايام لكن ياخذ
الظروف طلعان وكده فهو خلينا بيوتنا اهو
قاعدين جينا
شديد يعني خلينا السودان ومشينا وماشيين
بلد الناس لكن
السودان اتخرب كده
منطقه وادي حلفله تبعد 25 كيلومترا جنوبي
الحدود المصريه اصبحت مزدحمه بالنازحين
علما ان الخارجيه المصريه اكدت ارسال
تعزيزات لتسريعها فيما لا يزال نحو سته
الاف جواز سفر بانتظار تاشيرات الدخول
ابني بيستحق تاشيره
فراحوا قدم
للتاشيره ولغايه اليوم احنا ما لاقيين
يعني اجابه اهلي وادي حلفا يقدمون مساعدات
ولو بابسط الطرق لضيوفهم من الخرطوم والله
احنا ما اخترناش المدرسه هم في مبادره كان
من اهل المنطقه هنا
ودخلونا المدرسه ودون المراتب والملايات
شاي ولبن ومراد
ورغم الامهم فالابتسامه لا تفارق وجوه
بعضهم املا في غدا قد يعودون فيه لمنازلهم
وللحياه الامنه من المهندس العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات